yeah I know and welcome to this video
yeah this is a new rapid game on leeches
and I playing mutters Cooper 89 so c4 I
also play g3 in can play bottles c4 is
more of a mainstreamer choice maybe
leading to more transpositions
probably Kings engine yeah yep so is
looking forward to the analysis so just
informed him of the released release day
so um we have patrols and Kingstonian
going to shoot g5 and see what it does
this is the absolute main line the most
popular moves h6 yeah by the way there
haven't been any updates for the last
couple of days I didn't feel much like
playing I was really exhausted after
coming back from the German yeah I kept
saying Junior Championships but it's
probably the Germany Youth Championships
I know the definition is probably that
Junior means like under-20 and youth
means the like under 18 16 14 and so on
and it was some this event individual
championships for um yeah under 16 18
and so on
it was pretty um pretty exhausting I
didn't feel much like playing um yeah
I'm back now with the the record chest
maybe I would also
do some glitz but I'm currently not
really enjoying online glitz all that
much I don't know there are those I
think those up there up the up and down
times sometimes you enjoy it and then
then you somehow don't get the hang of
it
and currently I'm not enjoying it very
much I'd rather play some rapid chess
which is a bit relaxing at least so my
idea is to play before here immediately
SAA droops unprotected I expect him to
play Bishop d7 5070 em so that before
can be captured black might also insert
h6 here one thing um that was a bit
surprising is he did not play h6 and
that means I'm actually able to retreat
to e3 in case of black playing age six
yeah so here before doesn't really work
he can just take the pawn but I think a4
is something I don't need to address so
I played b3 in this position there are
situations where I can actually allow I
a 5 to a forward I'm really I'm very
uncertain when this is and when not and
he had the feeling that it's probably
not a great idea to allow it yeah night
h7 so he wants to play a 5 if I go v1
now I probably get before in not really
reliably and one thing is important this
is not a classical King Linnaeus in them
in the in the absolute purest form that
say we're white castles short and
there's this who comes first situation I
have not canceled him
so I can keep the king in the center if
I want okay and also the black attack if
he even if I have castled and he plays
f4 and g5 this is a lot slower than in
the classical Kings then you'll also
know that the night on s6 is somewhat
stuck the edge of the board and I would
now expect night c5 to be played no
that's interesting what is he doing here
I don't quite I can't go before now
right if I can do that I'm going to play
it I'm not going to think for this for
long time that must be desirable to keep
the night on a6 completely out of the
game he has to check on h4 Bishop f2 and
then potentially like 25 or so it I
don't quite think this is dangerous I
think I can just cancel them now you
have to somehow generate a concrete play
now quickly something and maybe taking
only 4 and when I don't look good but
I'm not quite sure I think blacks
position is already not that great
what he definitely cannot place f4 I
think this is immediately leading to a
terrible position unless there's
something like f4 bishop f2 Queen g5
attacking the pawn but can probably even
claim the G pawn now let's it's at least
a bit messy yeah for for human play we
sometimes really have to distinguish
between let's say a mathematical
computer like evaluation of a position
and what is
happening in a human game in some cases
the computer will just show a win for
one side or the advantage but it is not
easy to and to play the position in the
first place yeah I'm kind of curious
what what he is doing
normally you can just not afford to have
the knight stuck there on a six that's a
problem I'm close to 25 immediately is
is close to being playable all right
it's a very relaxed move so we should be
5 he wants to play of course I can
snatch the pawn on age 6 so is because
he's already doing something which is
slightly and desperate
yes not a not a bad bad idea
hmm to just I mean to make it messy so
if I take on age 6 what is black doing
maybe Bishop g5 or somewhere on your
site try to put the bishop on to e3
which is actually somewhat annoying I'm
actually I'm very tempted to simply
castle and say okay I'm winning on the
Queen side already why are you doing
I think I'm doing this it's a pragmatic
decision yeah so I just drop back I
don't want to trade the bishop and now
I'm ready form for Queen side action
with C 5 C 5 D takes there is Bishop
takes a 6 as a potential intermediate
move that could be quite strong but even
see 5 D takes B takes Knight takes
Knight C 4 is pretty awful sd-6 and so
on amazing strength retinol okay we'll
see what he does maybe Knight f6 it's
not not that I could have taken the pawn
on age 6 maybe this is the the right
choice and according to the engine
that's actually somewhat likely M the
computer yeah knows no fear quite in
quite clearly and I wonder if I actually
I can be file also be 595 b6 this is not
completely completely outlandish to
think
I probably probably c6 was okay then
okay so if I go c5 d takes e5 Bishop a6c
takes before is the thing and that I can
take b7 I'm not sure about this
TS c 5d takes b takes 94 is something
that i genuinely like him because it
opens up everything is very very quickly
and I'm not sure how good it is
objectively speaking five takes Bishop a
six-cd fights it's highly irritating its
meaning that think you can play it I
mean they're two two pieces hanging on
my end
and it's not entirely clear really I
still like the c5 thing it's very very
straightforward c5 details B takes
Knight takes Knight reform I still don't
know how convincing it is a you might
even have night a four and it looks very
strange but it might work
I don't know but c-5s is extremely
extremely principal tienda special
last night a for movement irritates me c
5 t takes 94-94 somehow I don't see it
would move them night 8 for Bishop a
force is losing temp T and I don't have
a good square for the Queen is the thing
you 23 doesn't work all that well
and maybe still threatening the 6 and
then threatening Knight takes e5 come on
out during this era it's it's really it
feels like almost the only wolf that is
sown that is powerful in some way Jim
Delano I can check though if he and
again I can check again if D takes
Bishop a6 is something details we should
base 6c beef why I really don't see
anything after that we should be 7s in
rugby area it's nothing RIT nothing
great after that
hmm Jim I mean I don't think black has
any sort of choice he has to take dc5
I'm threatening c6 winning and well he
has to take on c5 this just just no
other move at least I don't see another
move I mean maybe I'm overlooking some
substantial idea
so maybe I said he thought about Bishop
a6 again on something like that yeah I
know 94 was my idea so there are a
couple of things going on 90 85 is a
threat d6 is a threat the threat of d6
oh wow it was spread quickly
we are d6 I can take only 5 now taking
only 5 is probably strongest right 525
we should be form there is no trickery
we should III check take screen c3
bishop before winning the Queen and 9
takes g6 an important point is that I'm
actually attacking g6 so and must be
must be good almost the thing is d6 is
also good and probably not as powerful
as just taking it so let's take it that
was one of the threats md6 and Knight
takes d5
so what does he do there should be a -
maybe
okay not to move that from he's very
happy about probably but not a huge
choice okay it is still not hanging so
how do we how do we continue all this
Bishop d4 is very obvious looking move
but then Bishop f6
there's also the move d6 indisposition
d6 d6 pawn takes 95 looks pretty strong
d6 Queen takes however Queen takes pawn
takes and there is no obvious
continuation okay shorty form Bishop f6
Finn yeah you can maybe just just move
it back and Bishop d4 Bishop f6 move the
Knight to c4 threatening turning each
side but F takes e4 doesn't feel
entirely entirely clear
it doesn't don't feel entirely clear
really okay if I move the night
somewhere maybe 93 is actually not bad
not clear to me I can also take f5 can
still not take the night I take f5 mm I
have to filter it wrong to to take them
hmm I'm looking a little bit longer here
because the position looks like yam
blackest is struggling to stay in the
game
but I don't quite see how how this works
and if I can do I can do much still
feels reasonably stable the whole thing
I mean stable is stronger but I don't I
don't see anything super clear already
just taking I mean this is this is very
simple Luke took jigs
yeah I've wasted a lot of time and I
didn't really come to a clear conclusion
about anything
193 training of this I don't know it
doesn't it it is far less clear than I
was thinking come on I have to playoff
which is maybe not best but I have to
play it huh I mean I'm completely
certain that the computer finds
something very very good for white but I
didn't okay
MIT I can check on deform that is a good
move Bishop f6 35 so he cannot do this
and then be sure deform must be a good
move almost
knocking g8 looks and looks reasonably
forced
hmmm interesting that he invests time
why is this night six player in order to
answer a five with 90 xe3 and night XD 5
would be more than cheeky but ok so what
now yeah II 5 is the most obvious move
to play yeah just do it it should be
good for white can take c3 maybe then
attack d5 but I also tried an F form
that the bishop is trapped
don't see more for black nothing really
set aside to read taking Bishop a4 maybe
yeah maybe just attack the Queen and I
don't have very attractive squares yeah
this is actually an idea and Queenie one
is isn't it the big problem that I don't
have something and something very
aggressive okay so what's going on here
I can take on a form and I have f4
simply pushing this away for the mold or
e 6y 6 Knight takes Bishop takes Queen
takes however a 493 Bishop takes Queen
d5 F takes G 5 I don't see a tactic okay
so let's go
the bishop coming to c4 would be really
nice that would be extremely nice after
Bishop yeah where does it go actually to
e7 problem
yeah I can actually sing of playing 693
Bishop takes Queen d5 we should have
three you 693 Bishop 60 25 Bishop f3 and
the Queen has noble square Bishop c4
Celotex division
okay but can play a player I'm playing
it slow ish I have to also keep the time
situation in mind does he have like c5
or solo then I can take a form
yeah I was thinking would be three just
keeping it simple as simple as possible
Quincy one is probably also not bad this
is probably the easiest idea I don't
think I need to do all that great stuff
anymore those two pawns are extremely
strong just need to make sure they are
not blundering stuff night on h7 is not
good and so on
so even endings would be good
currently I'm threatening d6 winning
interposing or breaking the connection
between the bishop and the Rockland take
screen takers check so many maybe has
got the bishop at 7:00 at the end of
this line so I'm not sure if I'm
threatening d6 immediately but again I
don't need I don't need some
straightforward winning continuation it
would be nice to have it but it's such a
dominating situation that I don't think
I need something drastic okay so here
this is only two how to do it the only
active only active piece
going to be one is going Queen a4 I
assume but then night c1 would just I
know it talks a little bit under munis
and can I do something more direct I
don't see it at the moment another move
that is not bad as you gave to were
simply simply trade this thing yeah [ __ ]
come on
hey I am playing a simple movie 'm it
allows some Bishop c5 this is something
that I didn't like about this but I
don't know it shouldn't be a big issue
okay f4 is hanging I just spot that
can i Carol silk I don't know I don't
know if I can so just cover the pond
yeah so you can take this potentially I
just want to coordinate this a little
bit cannot go we should give four
unfortunately this is the strongest
piece I need to get rid of that what
oh my god did I just blunder f3i camel
am useless I'm useless what a joke
[Laughter]
there was a total demolition yes a Flex
position the whole game and I blunder
piece in one move Congrats
right the mid next next position was so
awful that's not even so easy to win now
maybe and he will manage somehow
first yeah the thing is it was really
bad fun that I didn't find some kind of
devastating blow earlier because it was
so terrible that there was certainly
something that should win the game
immediately and I didn't find it I
simply didn't didn't spot anything this
isn't this isn't so easy and just just
three second increment would seem
coward you air it wasn't wasn't an easy
thing I think I'll take that first no no
no no no no this isn't even a totally
easy draw I think because I have this
here in 95 this pawn structure is
slightly slightly weakened so if I go
age 3 it's got rock III set the thing
it's probably the right move now I
cannot go h3 here and fortunately yeah
look III is correct now I cannot do
anything we're still hoping and cannot
really draw him
there is no way to play h3 is the thing
you can take him yeah
I came so it's lucky that I've got to
draw after blundering the pawn which
editor the piece hood I mean man okay so
let's have a look there I'm really
wondering what I would have spoiled I
probably like +5 or something
I know there was a totally winning
position absolutely totally willing so
okay I'll decide work didn't do it for a
while
computer analysis after hit probably and
see what the engine finds yeah I know
that I have one very big blunder and
probably some mistakes yeah so black did
not play in early age six and this
allowed me to put the bishop back on 23
yeah but that feels comfortable and I
was I was thinking maybe 95 now it's so
before and here here I think the
position is really good and it were to
say what is the engine giving and that's
funny
oh wait F for Bishop F to Queen g5 you
have it why does Ted will even g4 is
just fantastic for white I'm really
amazed that the engine is is just giving
such a slow evaluation
okay just it's no depth really maybe it
gets better with this position is just
sucks for like I mean he's got really
bad pieces
yeah this is not a playable position for
lucky sorry right and it simply
disagreed and then the computer plays it
right actually not f1b should be three
twenty three leg is just pushed back
really looks that looks terrible
yeah okay here I can take aged six
there's nothing particularly wrong with
it I was thinking he might just might
have this idea I'm not sure that was
like getting this listen to me three
it's not enough but after castles I mean
I'm also just clearly better
so we'll see 5y + b6 surprised me so FK
is e4 was better
yeah I would really like to learn how I
can know there so d6 is in stronger or
95 does win and 94 is stronger okay but
I wasn't totally sure what to do now
I did 6 ound okay I mean this is
extremely logical
yeah that that looks extremely strong I
get this this coming yeah 93 I took a
long time but I mean it keeps it just an
advantage Joshua science I know this is
just should be towards caesium okay just
night before which I didn't spot oh yeah
here I was really thinking okay I'm
already having in the back I just don't
need just need to avoid to blunder stuff
and I'm minutes I'm blundering the
bloody of scholarship so what was
happening so I mean yeah I'm still
having it under control and then we
should be fine and just stupid
any normal move wins this is just far
too much those two pawns xgd six and
then all this is just not coordinated
yeah I mean blundering blundering for
peace
Jim
meaning you just continue because there
is dados to pong 24 I also felt strongly
not right
I would be too was actually stronger
winning the b-pawn okay yeah well we
didn't have much time
yeah understanding I wanted to you can
make sure not to use against the pawns
yeah yeah I was this was a bad thing
when she has so here's this down and I
don't have much down I wasn't playing
oops sorry
playing for that idea to to play the
night to the Father but he decided it
accurately here was the night coming to
g4 and here aged 3 there is 53 between
the lawyer played 55 threatening
whispered edges in the situation where
both sides cannot make any problems
he suggested a move should have taken
the 92 is still very bad position well
no no way exactly
holy somewhere here
I don't know what and he's still around
maybe he can tell me what it is yeah no
no yeah yeah yeah he's right this is a
terrible but the position is not good
yet this is the way the opening was
played on Black Lagoon in trouble he's
just stuck with the a6 line he suggested
this but that is really a terrible
ending I mean I can take whether the
computer wants to keep it on the board
yeah Queen B torso but this is this is
of course this good night eggs and now
the question is what exactly
engine wants to go h4 and nc5 make sense
them this is probably also not bad now
this is probably not bad but panel
should push this back and then clacey
five-acre came white white ass all the
strategic assets at Bishop airspace and
so on okay so um a draw at the end after
me blundering the whole thing away and
then being lucky that gathered us
somehow got the piece back yeah thanks
for watching